La început, tot ce trebuia era un formular.
Apoi a mai fost nevoie de unul. Și de încă unul.
Când procedura devine mai mare decât omul, avem o problemă.
O carte nu este doar un obiect. Este o lume în așteptare.
Paginile se deschid. Clădirile cresc chiar dintre ele.
Nu desenăm fiecare detaliu. Facem vizibilă posibilitatea.
Mașina poate produce un răspuns foarte convingător.
Dar ce anume îl susține? Urmărim legătura dintre sursă, proces și afirmație.
Acum îl putem verifica. Asta nu înseamnă că l-am dovedit adevărat.
Două uși deschise nu sunt, singure, o explicație a libertății.
Putem urma un obicei. Sau ne putem întreba de ce ne atrage.
Același pas. O altă relație cu propria alegere.